[Music]
I think there's no place on earth like
an article you can spend days and days
and days here without seeing any other
human being and it's just close as there
is to being alone on this planet it's
just so beautiful so majestic so
overwhelming you feel like you're part
of something much bigger it doesn't
matter where you live on this planet
what happens in Antarctica is going to
have a huge effect on our lives
[Music]
I think the magical part of it is that
you start realizing how connected
everything is and how it all ties back
to healthy eyes and without eyes there's
gonna be no leopard seals there's gonna
be no penguins
[Music]
climate change is of course the most
important the overarching issue of our
lifetimes
nature is running its course here on
impeded you know everything that needs
to be happening is happening and you
don't want that to change
creating marine protected areas provides
a certain resiliency to an ecosystem
that's otherwise under a lot of other
pressures all I know is that visual
communications is a very powerful tool
if we can share what this place feels
like what it smells like but it's you
know that every sensation that we have
with everybody else you can really
create a revolution when I go to bed at
night I think you know we may win we may
lose but at least we're going to try
with all the damage that we've done to
our planet if there's one place where we
could just leave it alone let it be here
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]